(upbeat music)
- [Voiceover] So Richard Wiseman of the
University of Hertfordshire
set up a website
called Laugh Lab to try
to find the funniest joke
in the world.
After about 40,000 submissions
rated by 1.5 million
people, he finally found
the world's funniest joke.
Two hunters are out int he woods
when one of them collapses.
He doesn't seem to be breathing
and his eyes are glazed.
The other guy whips
out his phone and calls
emergency service.
He gasps as he says, "My friend is dead!
"He's dead! What can I do?"
The operator says, "Hey, calm down.
"I can help.
"First, let's just make
sure he's actually dead."
Then there's a silence and all of a sudden
a gunshot's heard.
And then the guy gets back on the phone.
He says, "Okay, what now?"
Nothing?
- [Woman] No.
- Come on, you know that's good.
You know it's good, there's a smile.
Oh, oh. Almost.
(sad music)
Did you not hear the joke?
- I heard it.
- [Host] I'm gonna read it one more time,
'cause I just don't think you guys get
really good humor, 'cause
this is like really good joke.
It's proven.
I'm gonna do it one more time.
You guys ready?
Two hunters out in the woods
(upbeat music)
when one of them collapses.
Oh no! Calls 9-1-1.
My friend's dead, what can I do?
The operator says, "Hey, calm down.
"First, you just gotta make
sure he's actually dead."
And all of a sudden gunshot noise.
The guy gets back on the phone and says,
"Okay, now what?"
Ha, ha, ha.
Ahh, ahh, wow.
Maybe you just don't
have a sense of humor?
- Oh, shit.
- You get it?
- Yeah, I definitely get it.
- Ha, ha, ha, ha.
(fake laughing)
Was that a tiny laugh?
- Yeah, that was a tiny laugh, bro.
Oh, that's a laugh there.
That's a, that's a kind
of a-- that's a laugh.
That's a laugh.
Oh my gosh, ha, ha, ha, ha.
So much funny.
I mean, I don't know.
I think I heard some laughter.
Close enough, so thank you
guys so much for playing.
Wow. I am the funniest
person you've ever met?
- (laughs) Wait--
- Look at-- more laughter.
- Wait a minute, wait a minute.
Let's not get ahead of ourselves here.
- I mean, I made you
laugh like on command.
This joke is still the best joke ever.
Bam, proven.
And the guy says, "Okay, now what?"
Nothing?
- [Woman] No.
- Ahh, stone cold.